[MUSIC PLAYING]
OLIVER ROEDER: Hey.
All right.
Hi, Google.
Thank you for having me.
I'm Oliver Roeder.
I'm a senior writer
at FiveThirtyEight,
and I am also FiveThirtyEight's
puzzle editor.
And I have a book out, which is
our first ever FiveThirtyEight
book, which is a collection
of my puzzle called
"The Riddler", subtitle
"Fantastic Puzzles"
from FiveThirtyEight.
So today I just kind
of want to talk to you
about what "The Riddler" is
and what FiveThirtyEight is,
and what I do.
But I also want to
involve the audience.
So there will be some
participatory puzzles
toward the end, and prizes,
and people will come on stage,
and it'll be very exciting.
So if this were a
normal book talk,
it would be very easy for
me because I could just
read from my book and I
wouldn't have to do anything.
This is not a normal book.
It's a puzzle book.
But I do want to read
you about two paragraphs
from the introduction
just to kind of give you
a sense of what
this is all about.
And I think if you like
what I say, you can buy one
and I'll be happy to
sign it afterwards.
So let me drink
some water first.
How about that Amazon, huh?
I expected a lot more
scooters and stuff.
"In 1865, the British Museum
received a brittle and breaking
scroll of papyrus.
The document was
discovered in Egypt
in the ruins of the Mortuary
Temple of Pharaoh Ramses II.
It was well over 3,000
years old and worse
for the wear,
pictured on the left.
At the museum, curators
carefully unrolled
its two sides and placed
them in two glass frames.
One side had a jagged gash and
the other had a blank section
about 10 feet long.
Yet despite its rough
condition, much of the document
could still be painstakingly
deciphered and translated,
and it became known
as the Rhind Papyrus
after the antiquarian
who had purchased it.
Its text begins, quote, 'The
entrance into the knowledge
of all existing things
and all obscure secrets.'
What followed turned out
to be the world's oldest
collection of math puzzles.
The problems posed
in the Rhind Papyrus
won't present much of a
challenge to the modern reader,
especially for those of
you holding this book,
or holding this book
after you purchase it.
One of its problems, for
example, reads, quote,
'Find the volume of a
cylindrical granary of diameter
nine and height 10.'
Another, 'Sum the geometrical
progression of five terms
of which the first term is
seven and the multiplier seven.'
But now these puzzles
serve a grander purpose.
The 84 problems and solutions
recorded on the Papyrus
provide some of the
clearest insights
into the numerical methods of
the ancient Egyptians, some
of the world's earliest
mathematicians."
So this is a very long
tradition into which
FiveThirtyEight and The Riddler
puzzle column is entering,
and that's what I want
to talk about today.
So one sort of
hurdle that we want
to get people to jump
over with The Riddler
is this idea that I'm
not good at math, right?
The truth is, I'm not
all that good at math.
And many people say this,
including my boss, Nate Silver,
the founder and editor in
chief of FiveThirtyEight,
who says that in the
foreword to this very book.
So one way to do this, I think,
is with engaging math puzzles,
puzzles that tell
stories, puzzles
that have many different
angles of attack,
and puzzles that don't echo
the things that you didn't like
about math class in school.
But this is a very
self-selected kind
of audience, extreme
selection bias.
I gave this talk once before.
And I remember it
going really well,
but there is a key
difference between that time
and this time, and it's that
time, people were drinking.
So it already feels different.
So lots and lots of people
have tried to do this.
I keep thinking there's
going to be a screen here.
Lots and lots of people
have tried to do this.
We're very far from the first.
And like I said, this has
been a long, long tradition,
of which we are just
the most recent entrant.
And chief among these
people, in my mind,
is Martin Gardner, who I imagine
many of you have heard of.
So for, what is
it, 30 or so years,
he wrote a monthly column
in "Scientific American"
called Mathematical
Games every month.
And it became so popular
and was such a driver
of sales and subscriptions of
"Scientific American" that they
moved it right to the
front of the magazine
so that people
didn't waste any time
and they could get right to it.
In fairness to myself,
my column is weekly.
Martin Gardner's
column was monthly.
And Gardner's columns
were collected--
it took me, like, 90
minutes to figure out
how to make it do this.
So please appreciate that--
were collected into many,
many, many, many books, many
not pictured on
this slide, which
may be in the back of
the mind of my publisher.
But so far, my output is
significantly smaller,
and this is my first book.
So what Gardner said,
"One of the pleasures
of writing the column
was that it introduced me
to so many top mathematicians,
which of course I was not.
Their contributions to my column
were far superior to anything
I could write and were a major
reason for the column's growing
popularity."
I feel exactly the same
way, except rather than
top mathematicians, it's
FiveThirtyEight readers.
So The Riddler column
is a very participatory,
collaborative endeavor.
I'm called the puzzle
editor for a reason.
I don't write most
of the puzzles.
I get ideas from
our very numerate
and generous and
bright readership
that I mold into something
that we can publish.
And I go back and
forth with readers
about puzzles and
solutions, and I'm
merely the sort of
conduit of this funnel,
to mix my metaphors.
And it's really a
reader-driven enterprise.
So I'm harping on
Martin Gardner,
but I think it's
really illustrative.
Martin Gardner introduced,
via his math column,
many things to the broader
world which are now, I think,
extremely familiar.
Probably most of you have heard
or seen most of these things,
and they're not
even really thought
of as something that would
come from a math column
right there in sort of a
broader cultural category now.
And that's what we hope
that The Riddler will do,
is introduce people
to ideas that
become very familiar to them
and are not sort of locked away
in a math book or math
class or something.
So I'll go very briefly
through what is--
how many people are familiar
with FiveThirtyEight?
Wow, literally everyone?
Well, I'll do this very quickly.
We used to be known for filling
in maps with different colors.
And now we're known
for all kinds of stuff.
As I was talking to
a gentleman before,
I'm currently on world chess
championship coverage duty
and scheduled this
talk for today
because it's an off day in
the world chess championship.
So we're really kind of
taking this empirical world
view to everything-- culture,
sports, economics, science,
and of course, politics,
which I think we're
happy the election is over.
But our chart is a
little sad this week.
So you guys like technology
and all that kind of stuff.
So let me just talk
a little very quickly
about the logistics.
How does this column
come together every week?
So you guys have email here?
Yeah, I have email.
Well, that's not my fault.
That's my employer's fault.
So I have email, and my
very own email account.
And every-- see, when
people are drunk,
that got a much bigger laugh.
So readers will send
me all kinds of stuff,
germs of puzzle ideas, fully
fledged puzzles, something
that they noticed
in their daily life.
The puzzle-- I think it was last
week someone, their landline
and their cell phone had
the exact same digits, just
an anagram of the digits.
And the guy emailed
me just saying,
I noticed this in real life.
So we made it a math puzzle.
What are the odds that
one of my phone numbers
is an anagram of digits
of another one of my phone
numbers?
So these come in.
I pick one, I mold
it, I write it up,
I send that to my editors.
We publish it on
FiveThirtyEight.
And then readers will go email
me answers, tweet me answers.
See, that's a Google
product, Google form.
All kinds of stuff.
I funnel this into another
document, it gets edited,
and we put up the solution.
So this is kind of
the lifespan of a math
puzzle at FiveThirtyEight.
Oh, and then they take
all that and turn it
into a book, which you can buy.
I think it's actually
cheaper up there.
So all of this
collaboration has given rise
to Riddler Nation,
which is the name
of our collective sort of
universe of readers and fans.
And so not only on
FiveThirtyEight.com,
but on people's blogs and
GitHubs and other websites,
people post their ideas,
their solutions, extensions
to the problems.
And it sort of created
sort of an ecosystem kind
of that exists online
around the puzzle itself,
which is very exciting for me.
So I showed you a slide
earlier of what Gardner
has introduced to the world.
And these are some
of the things much,
much less popular than
Gardner's, but that The Riddler
has kind of started to
introduce into the world.
And I should note
very prominently
that almost all of these are
reader-created images that
resulted from a puzzle
that we published.
So for example, Planetary
Guardians was a puzzle.
Two aliens land on the
surface of a planet, each
with a piece of a bomb that
will destroy that planet,
as aliens do.
And there is a
guardian who needs
to stop them from getting
together and assembling that.
And the question
was, at what speed
relative to the
speed of the aliens
does the guardian
need to go to ensure
he saves the planet x percent
of the time, whatever?
And it turns out to be
very, very difficult.
But that's kind of
what it looks like,
and that's how that reader
chose to approach the problem.
Let's see.
Oh, Picky Eating is imagine
that you were an eater so picky,
and you hated the
crust of your bread
so much, that you would
only eat those portions
of the sandwich closer to
the center than to the crust.
And how much of the
sandwich would you eat?
And it sounds pretty easy.
It's actually a little
bit tricky geometrically.
And that just shows
as your sandwich--
I mean, triangular sandwich,
hexagonal sandwich, et cetera,
and sort of the asymptotic
behavior of your eating.
And the Pringle of Probability
we'll come back to later.
Laser Larry was about a guy
named Laser Larry attacking
Riddler headquarters.
And there's tons and
tons of examples.
These just look cool.
We have puzzles
about baking cakes,
about making tables
efficiently from various sizes
of rectangular wood,
and a dodge-ball duel,
except with three people.
So I'm going to walk you through
just one more example quickly
of kind of what all
this looks like.
And I honestly
don't remember what
comes after that in
this presentation.
So we'll find out together.
So we posed this puzzle
about a martini glass.
And you've drunk
enough of your martini
such that the drink reached a
certain fraction up the side.
You tilted it so
it was just barely
to the point of spilling.
How far up the other
side does it reach?
And I won't walk through
all the math right now.
You should try it when
you get back to your desk
because I'm sure you don't
anything better to do.
But this is kind of what my
Twitter looks like the day
after we publish something.
So we have the very math-y
folks, the theoretical folks,
we have the empirical folks.
And we have the people
who just say, screw math.
And this is really,
really fun to see
different kind of approaches,
both serious and not.
And then I cull
all that together,
and this is literally
what we publish.
This is what the column
looked like the next week.
So we pick out some
diagrams, typeset some math,
write some words, and so on.
OK.
This one is something that came
to us from one of our readers
who was a NASA scientist.
And you can talk to
your partner or your row
or your neighbor,
whatever you call it.
But talk amongst yourselves
for a couple minutes.
So what's going on here is
you have this menu of items,
and you are a space agency.
And your goal is to arrive
an alien artifact first.
And you have a budget,
which is $1 billion,
and there are various things
that you can buy, and fuel,
as listed here.
But there's only a certain
amount of them in the world.
So why don't we take, like,
two minutes or three minutes,
however long it takes, and
then we can kind of discuss.
And whoever gets
there first, I will
buy them a book at the end.
How about that?
That's exactly right.
So there's one way.
This is the fastest
you can get there.
But if you hoard the
world's xenon, as one does--
so very, very good.
Team effort.
I love it.
I'm going to give a good report
to your managers when I leave.
Very good.
So this took me even longer
than the other thing.
OK.
I'm going too fast.
There's going to be two
participatory Riddlers
that I think will be less
painful than the one that
preceded them.
There will be one puzzle
that will have two winners.
Those two winners
will join me on stage.
From those two, there
will be one winner,
and that winner will get a
prize, which will be my book,
and I will sign it for you.
I'll buy it for you, and
then sign it for you.
OK.
So this was a
Riddler last summer.
And what you are going to do
is pick a positive integer.
The person who
submits the lowest
integer which no one else has
chosen will be one winner.
And then, since we
need two, the person
who picks the second lowest
integer that no one has chosen.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
I'm sure it does.
So you can take out your
cellular telephone and navigate
to tiny.cc/smallnumber.
There should be a
Google form with which
I'm sure you're very familiar.
And please put your
name or something
to identify you, your
nickname, and your number.
And if you don't have a phone,
I don't know what to tell you.
All right.
Moment of truth.
I guess we need to sort it.
How do we do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVER ROEDER: 2.
Dave.
Where are you, Dave?
AUDIENCE: I'm here.
OLIVER ROEDER: All right.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
And I think there
were no 5's, but there
is a unique 7, which is Adam.
Adam, come on up.
OK.
Well-chosen.
Yes, I will scroll down.
Brad B, class clown.
I'm happy to share this later.
OK.
So the original post
was July 28, 2017.
So if you look at the week
after that, you can find it.
OK.
OK, OK, OK.
So this is where you
two now find yourselves.
You are contestants on a hot new
game show called Highest Number
Wins.
So you're really going to change
your mindset from low number
to high number.
So what's going to
happen is you'll
each go into a secret
booth, not pictured.
And you're going to receive a
random number, not an integer
this time, but a random
number between 0 and 1.
And your decision will
be to keep that number
or to ditch it,
in which case you
will get a second random
number, independently
random number between
0 and 1, in which case
you have to keep it.
So you have one opportunity to
kick it out and get a new one,
or you can keep the first one.
And whoever of you
has the higher number
at the end will win
the grand prize.
Does that make sense?
So we're going to have to do
some sort of jerry rigging
of the secret booth
since there are so
many screens around here.
So do you have a
preference who goes first?
I guess you had
the lowest number.
Would you like to
go first or second?
AUDIENCE: I'll go first.
OLIVER ROEDER: So I
guess you will have
to maybe look at the curtain.
This is an honor
system thing here.
OK.
And audience, please keep your
jubilant--your reactions have
been so jubilant thus far,
I'm a little bit worried about
what's going to
happen So please no--
my two least favorite things
are speaking in public
and operating my computer
while people are watching me.
So this is--
I think this will work.
Can people see this?
Yeah?
OK.
All right.
So you understand
what's about to happen.
AUDIENCE: I think I do.
OLIVER ROEDER: So you're
going to get a random number
between 0 and 1.
You're going to decide whether
you want to keep that number,
and that will be
your number forever,
or if you want to throw it
away and get a second one.
If you get a second
one, you must keep it.
So since we don't actually
have soundproof booths,
how about if you like your first
number, give me the thumbs up.
That means you keep it.
If you don't like it,
give me the thumbs down
and I'll give you a new one.
So if you like your number,
if you don't like your number.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OLIVER ROEDER: OK?
I can do that.
OLIVER ROEDER: OK.
Here we go.
OK.
You're going to remember--
I remembered what it is.
OK, sorry.
Ignore that, please.
Ignore that.
I just wanted to go back.
All right.
You have your number?
Everybody knows
what the number is.
OK.
Second player, you
can-- and I guess
you can look now that
you're locked in.
Are you ready?
AUDIENCE: I'm ready.
I'd like another one.
OLIVER ROEDER: OK.
The moment of truth.
You can reveal your number
now since all decisions
have been made.
AUDIENCE: .69 Pretty good.
OLIVER ROEDER: .69.
Very, very well put, yeah.
AUDIENCE: What was the
one that you rejected?
Or was that your first?
AUDIENCE: It was
.2 something, or--
OLIVER ROEDER: All right.
Ready?
AUDIENCE: .2 is terrible.
Is it-- no.
AUDIENCE: .02
OLIVER ROEDER: Oh.
Bravo.
Congratulations.
AUDIENCE: I never
win games of skill.
OLIVER ROEDER: OK.
You're welcome to stay there
or go back to your seats.
It's almost over.
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OLIVER ROEDER: So this was
a problem on The Riddler,
and a ton of people played.
And the winning--
did I say what the--
and we had random
matchups of people.
But there's some math, some
real math behind this, some game
theoretic math.
Obviously, assumptions about the
players' payoffs and so forth.
But this is kind of
what the solution
to a problem like this we would
publish on FiveThirtyEight.
So even if you don't think
through the game theory,
you can still submit, and
it can be interesting,
and then there's
kind of another layer
of what is a sort of theoretical
solution to this problem.
And one way to think
about it is that you
have a cutoff value,
which I'm sure both of you
kind of had in the back
of your mind as something
higher than which
I'm going to keep
and lower than which
I'm going to reject.
And a key to
solving this problem
is to recognize, well, if I get
exactly that cutoff number, I'm
indifferent between
accepting and rejecting,
and the math kind
of flows from there.
So the probability that
you win if you keep C
must be equal to the probability
that you win if you ditch C.
And you can just
do some algebra.
You get a pretty simple
quadratic, which you can solve.
And does anybody recognize
what game theoretically optimal
cutoff, what that number is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVER ROEDER: Yeah, the
Golden Ratio, the Golden Ratio
conjugate, what
Golden Ratio minus 1.
So that's pretty cool.
And this problem can be solved
visually from both players
in three dimensions using
the Pringle of Probability.
And that's that.
So I'm really happy to
take questions or talk
about anything else.
And I'm happy to stick around
and talk after and sign
books and all that stuff, too.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Who's going to win
the world chess championship?
OLIVER ROEDER: That's
a very good question.
I would say-- well, Carlsen
is the heavy favorite.
The question is how heavy.
And I would say Caruana, like
plus 500, something like that
if you could get that.
I don't know, because
if it remains drawn,
Carlsen's much stronger
rapid and blitz player.
So I would still take Carlsen.
I don't know what the money
line is on him, though.
There's been four games.
They've all been drawn.
So it's very tense.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: How do you recommend
improving your intuition
around some math
problem like this?
How ca we learn?
OLIVER ROEDER: That's
a good question.
I mean, my stock answer is
just like do The Riddler a lot.
So in the book, for example--
I don't have a great
answer for you.
But in the book, I've tried
to organize the problems
from easy to hard.
And in the column we
have two versions.
One is called Riddler
Express and one
is called Riddler Classic.
And oftentimes
the Express puzzle
will be a simplified version
of the Classic puzzle.
So ideally, if we
do our job right,
there'll be pieces
of the intuition
from the more complicated
puzzle kind of embedded
within the simple puzzle.
But yeah, I think just exposure.
Like for example,
crossword puzzles.
The only way to get good
at crossword puzzles
is to do crossword puzzles.
There's no other way.
Or like language
immersion or whatever.
I don't know.
That's a very unsatisfactory
answer, I know.
But do math puzzles.
I don't know.
Martin Gardner books.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you feel like
the style with which you've
presented and explained these
puzzles has changed over time?
Do feel like you've
used like more
or less technical language, or
just generally style changes?
OLIVER ROEDER: That's a
really interesting question,
which I haven't thought
about until right now.
I would guess that
the language has
gotten less technical
for a couple of reasons.
One is since we have a big
readership that often publishes
on their own
websites about this,
I've been able to outsource
a little bit of that.
So I could say, well, for
this derivation of this part,
you can see this guy's
excellent, or girl's excellent,
woman's excellent solution.
And so I am able
to outsource a bit.
Second is just I think we've
kind of found our cadence,
and just we use a lot less
LaTeX math typesetting nowadays.
Have you noticed a trend
one way or the other?
AUDIENCE: I haven't really.
I've noticed generally, I guess,
some technical publications
obviously getting more or
less technical over time.
OLIVER ROEDER: Yeah,
that's a good question.
Thank you.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What is the
most unintuitive solution
to a problem you've seen?
OLIVER ROEDER: The
most unintuitive.
So I think I have an answer
to that, which has to do--
so it has to do with
this Lonesome King puzzle
on the bottom right there.
So what this puzzle
is, is it goes
by another name, which
is rather dark, which
is Group Russian Roulette.
So these are a bunch of people.
A dot is a person,
and they randomly
shoot at another person
in a huge circle.
And if you get shot, you die.
And the question is
what are the chances
that there is a single
person left at the end,
as opposed to 0 people?
And this is incredibly,
incredibly hard.
And the answer is about
50%, but not exactly 50%.
And it doesn't
approach 50%, either.
It oscillates depending on
the initial size of the crowd.
So if there's,
like, 10,000 people
or 20,000 people
or 30,000 people,
it's very, very strange.
And there's actually
an academic math paper
about this that basically says
this is really, really weird.
So that's one example.
AUDIENCE: What's the
most surprising field
of math someone has
used in a solution
that you really enjoyed?
OLIVER ROEDER: Most
surprising field of math.
That is a good question.
So I would say
just as background,
tons of like combinatorics
are happening.
Lots of simulation Monte
Carlo stuff gets used.
Probability.
We haven't had much or
like topology type stuff.
People submit in very
interesting programming
languages sometimes.
It's a really good question.
I don't have a great answer.
But the media that people use
from cocktail napkins to Python
and everything in between is
always really heartening for me
to see.
Let me think about that.
If you're still around,
I'll let you know.
What percentage of people
misunderstand the question
or get the question
wrong or both?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, both.
OLIVER ROEDER: It is
extremely high variance.
So there's extremely high
variance, in first of all,
the number of people
who submit answers.
So I would say the average is
on the order of a few thousand.
But I would say the variance
is on the order of, like, 1,000
or something.
And there's a
selection issue, which
is you're more likely to
submit an answer if you
think your answer is right,
I think, generally speaking.
If I had to guess, I would say
60% to 70% correct on average.
But there's a huge
band around that.
The Riddler Classic,
which is the harder one,
last week we got three
answers submitted,
which was the fewest
we've ever gotten.
It was just-- see,
and now I keep
remembering that this is
going to be tweeted to, like,
15 million people or whatever.
So it was very
hard and involved.
And so I think that's why,
not that it was difficult,
necessarily.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
OLIVER ROEDER: No, please.
AUDIENCE: Does Nate Silver
give performance reviews
with a Band of Uncertainty?
OLIVER ROEDER: Again, see- no.
No.
We are subject to certain
corporate policies of the Walt
Disney Corporation,
and they govern that.
Well, it's like 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, plus or minus 0.
But I will suggest that to him.
Or give bonuses with
a Band of Uncertainty.
Roll the dice.
Yeah.
Or we could just do Wolfram
Alpha and click the button.
AUDIENCE: Does your
interest in politics
extend to other
kinds of puzzles?
You mentioned
crosswords earlier.
OLIVER ROEDER: Yes.
Crosswords are a
big hobby of mine.
So I competed a couple of
times in the American Crossword
Puzzle Tournament,
which is like the de
facto national championship.
And one of my claims
to journalistic fame
was I broke a crossword
plagiarism scandal
and got the crossword
editor of the "USA
Today" removed from his duties.
This was, I guess, a victory
for FiveThirtyEight data
journalism, and it's a
relatively interesting story.
So a computer programmer
web scraped 50,000 something
crossword puzzles from
all different outlets
and put them into this
format that he had created.
And one thing you could
do with this database
is match two pairs
of puzzles, basically
like a similarity score.
And these two puzzles
have 3% match or 5% match
or 0% match, whatever.
And what we found was that all
of the puzzles that matched
came from two outlets.
One was "USA Today" and
one was a syndicated puzzle
called Universal--
and it used to be
called Universal Press
Syndicate or something.
And they were both
edited by the same guy.
So this really crazy fact
dropped out of this data set.
So that happened, and
then we paired that
with traditional reporting.
So I went to the library
and pulled the microfilm
to make sure this was actually
the puzzle in the paper
that day for a bunch of them.
Sorry, this is probably not what
you wanted me to talk about.
But this is the question
answerer's prerogative.
You can ask whatever you want.
I can answer whatever I want.
And he took the
microphones away.
Yeah, so and then we obviously
called this guy for comment
and talked to people
in the crossword world
and that kind of stuff.
So I love crossword puzzles.
I'm good, not great
at solving them.
Other puzzles.
I can't do, what's
it called, Sudoku.
I can't.
I don't know what
it is about me.
I just-- not can't
like I hate them.
Like I don't know
how to solve them.
KenKen, too.
I don't know what it is.
Maybe I just haven't
devoted enough time.
But what about you?
AUDIENCE: I'm a big fan
of crossword puzzles.
OLIVER ROEDER:
Have you ever tried
to create a crossword puzzle,
construct a crossword puzzle?
I haven't made one yet.
But you saw that
article, "New York Times"
did a series on how to make
your own crossword puzzle?
OLIVER ROEDER: I did, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's
got me thinking.
OLIVER ROEDER: I've
tried to make one,
and I found it
extremely difficult.
I heard there's an internal
Google crossword puzzle.
Is that true?
AUDIENCE: I haven't
heard of one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
OLIVER ROEDER: OK.
That's cool.
I'm not as familiar with
cryptics, but I like them.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
OLIVER ROEDER: Thank you.
Sorry, was there something else?
AUDIENCE: I was just curious.
You know, I do various types
of puzzles, and some of them
are just find the
lateral thinking that
gets you to the answer.
And these are very different.
And I was wondering,
first of all,
whether the same kind of
person is attracted both,
and also whether you
find that it tickles
the same part of your brain,
or if it's something very
different for you, or
if one type of puzzle
draws you to another
type of puzzle.
OLIVER ROEDER: Crosswords
and The Riddler
is my puzzle diet, yeah.
OK.
Thank you, everyone, so
much for spending your lunch
hour with me.
I really appreciate it.
And yeah, I'll be back there.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]